nous à thème un aphte il essayiste
auteur de la révolution à la
restauration où va la tunisie
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors quelques
tensions identifiant ce qu'on peut
espérer quand même que des
rassemblements vont bien se passer
tout est fait pour
pour que les manifestations se passe mal
c'était dire que alors officiellement le
le pouvoir invoquer des raisons
sanitaires pour justifier l'interdiction
cdc interdiction qui ont été décrétée
mercredi donc le 12 pour et qui commence
à quoi à partir du 13
ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres c'est
les déclarations du gouverneur donc
l'équivalent du préfet de tunis qui a
très proche du président qui a bien
expliqué qu' il était effectivement été
porter allégeance enfin il prêté
allégeance au président de la république
et s'en est pris à l'opposition donc
sortant totalement de son rôle de deux
grands commis de l'état donc s'est
clairement positionné et si on avait un
doute sur sur cette interdiction met les
doutes ont été dissipées par les prises
de positions très hostile aux
manifestants aussi bien du gouverneur de
tunis que du ministère de l'intérieur
donc au moins c'est clair c'est
politique le président de la république
a décidé de manière unilatérale en
décembre qu'il fallait commémorer le 17
décembre est pas le 14 janvier et c'est
ce n'est pas anodin c'est c'est le fond
même de sa de son idéologie parce qu'il
estime que tout ce qui a été entrepris à
partir du 14 janvier donc à partir de la
fille de ben ali et ta rasé et a
recommencé d'oxo ce n'est pas qu'une
question de date c'est vraiment très
idéologique et donc il a voulu
l'interdiction de de ce 14 janvier
précision ça a déjà été entrepris
l'année dernière par le gouvernement
d'haïti chi chi
qui était soutenu par l'art dacquigny
manifeste donc ce qui affaiblit un petit
peu une partie de l'opposition parce que
l'année dernière ne trouvait rien à
redire à l'interdiction des
manifestations à cette année elle se
pose en victime mais pas tout mais pas
toute l'opposition par ailleurs il ya
des personnes qui ont contesté la
décision de l'année dernière et la
décision de cette aide alors plusieurs
choses 1 dans ce que vous venez de dire
je vais peut-être d'abord rebondir
selon vous ce n'est pas donc une raison
sanitaire pour laquelle le président
wade a empêché en cette célébration une
raison politique pour quelle raison
justement
side ne veut que les gens qui le
soutiennent je rappelle que le 25
juillet donc le jour où il a wheel
appris où il s'est arrogé les pleins
pouvoirs ça a été fait à la suite d'une
manifestation
donc un petit peu partout en tunisie la
journée du 25 juillet au 25 juillet la
tunisie était dans une situation
catastrophique du point de vue sanitaire
était en confinement total et en couvre
feu ça n'a pas ça n'a pas empêché le
président de la république de célébrer
ces manifestations donc illégal pour le
coup pour les mêmes raisons sanitaires
et ça n'a pas empêché de prendre un bain
de foule sur la même avenue bourguiba
qui est bloquée aujourd'hui
le soir alors qu'il y avait un couvre
feu nocturne donc c'est à dire que les
considérations sanitaires ça jamais été
le fort du président de la république ça
l'a pas gêné parce que il y avait des
gens qui pour le coup le soutenaient le
25 juillet aujourd'hui des personnes qui
sont contre lui et il veut pas entendre
parler de la moindre opposition il ne
souffre aucune critique alors très
rapidement messieurs natif désolé on est
pressé par le temps est ce que vous
estimez que l'opposition en tunisie est
divisée aujourd'hui oui il y à des
oppositions et des oppositions
irréconciliables il y à une personne qui
ont exercé le pouvoir notamment autour
du parti islamiste ennahda qui a déjà eu
recours à ce genre de ce genre de
pratique pour interdire des
manifestations
donc ça affaiblit aujourd'hui sa
position il ya des parties notamment des
partis de gauche de centre gauche qu'ils
ont toujours opposé à
à toute à toutes les pressions du droit
de manifester sur un petit peu plus
audible mais beaucoup moins nombreuses
sur la rue et puis d'un troisième type
d'opposition s'est rhabillé moussy qui
est issu de l'ancien régime on a trois
oppositions qui ne se parlent pas qu'ils
ne peuvent pas se parler parce qu'elles
n'ont pas les mêmes objectifs et c'est
ce qui fait la force de taille
s'arrêtent parce qu'en face il n'y a pas
un front uni à thème un à petit un merci
à vous d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes auteur de la
révolution à la restauration où va la
tunisie merci à vous d'avoir été en
direct avec nous